we have never added a new programming
language to Android and today we're
making Kotlin an officially supported
language in andhra at google i/o we
announced that we're adding kopplin is
an officially supported language for
android Kotlin is a mature and fun
language that many developers are
already embracing for the production
apps for those of you who want to try
cutland for the first time we're now
bonding the Kotlin plugin with android
studio
3.0 when creating a new project you can
now choose to enable coupling support
and any template will be generated in
that language for you because Copeland
plays well with Java you can also start
adding Kotlin to your existing projects
try converting a single Java file to
cuddlin using this androids to your
command or add a new code template and
select Kotlin as the source language
when taking first steps with programming
and Kotlin you might also find it useful
to migrate code snippets from java by
simply copy and pasting them to Copeland
files and Android studio will convert
the code for you on the fly refer to our
blog post on Android developers for a
quick tour of the Kotlin language you'll
also find links to the full reference
pages there we're just starting with
Kotlin as a supported language for
Android so expect to see more
documentation samples and Android
specific guidance in the near future and
in the meantime I hope you have fun
exploring Kotlin
[Music]